[Música]
a lo largo de la vida todos los seres
humanos ganan ciertas cosas como amigos
experiencias viajes entre otras cosas
materiales
pero también se ven expuestos a perder
relaciones metas sueños y sin ser
realmente conscientes estas pequeñas
pérdidas nos preparan para pérdidas
mucho más grandes
entre ellas la más conocida y temible
muerte para los que se van y el temible
duelo para quienes nos quedamos
yo no fui consciente de esto hasta el
día en el que falleció mi mamá para ser
más exactos el día de su velatorio que
si bien recibimos un montón de flores y
asistieron familiares y amigos de toda
la vida me di cuenta que la mayoría por
no decir todos no sabían cómo tratarme
realmente les costaba mirarme a los ojos
y cada vez que yo les decía algo pensaba
en mil veces antes de responderme tiempo
después me di cuenta de cómo no iban a
estar incómodos si nunca habíamos
hablado sobre la muerte o sobre cómo
tratar una persona que está atravesando
un duelo
sé que es un tema difícil y casi nadie
habla de él no sé si por el hecho de
creer que si no se habla de algo no
sucede pero si a todos nos va a tocar en
algún momento no sería mejor saber que
pensamos y sentimos sobre ello la muerte
siempre estado y siempre va a estar lo
que hizo la pandemia fue evidenciar la y
mostrarnos que no somos para siempre y
que realmente el problema no es que nos
vamos a morir el problema es que tememos
irnos sin estar realmente seguros que
hemos disfrutado y vivido la vida que
nos tocó
nos da miedo la incertidumbre el qué va
a pasar cuando ya no estemos acá y
adónde vamos a ir porque eso sigue
siendo un misterio pero creo que si
empezamos a hablar sobre las personas
que hemos perdido y sobre qué pensamos
sobre la muerte va a llegar un punto en
el que vamos a sentirnos más cómodos con
ella
soy antonella leon comunicadora y hace 4
años que creo contenido de comedia en
las redes sociales en el camino me di
cuenta de la importancia de contar tu
historia
así que me animé a hablar sobre cómo
haber perdido a mi mamá a los 23 años ha
sido una de las experiencias más
difíciles y a la vez más transformadora
y positiva de mi vida mi mamá falleció
de cáncer fueron siete años en los que
mi vida y la de mi familia fue una
montaña rusa llena de nuevas
experiencias dudas y preguntas en
respuestas
durante todo ese tiempo no pudimos
asimilar lo que nos había pasado
simplemente ya estábamos en esa
situación y tocaba seguir y hacerse
cargo
pero cuando mi mamá falleció hace tres
años decidí compartir con mi comunidad
lo que estaba viviendo y lo que pensaba
sobre el duelo fue en ese momento en el
que recibí muchísimos mensajes en los
que completos desconocidos me abrían su
corazón y me contaban sobre sus pérdidas
lo curioso es que todas estas historias
terminaban con dos preguntas
cómo puedo hacer para que no me duela
más cuéntame qué hiciste tú
y por más que me esforzaba en darles
consejos y mensajes de aliento me di
cuenta que no existe una fórmula para
llevar el duelo que lo que me sirvió a
mí no necesariamente te servirá a ti y
es porque existen otros factores que
influyen en la situación que está
pasando llega un momento en el que
tienes que sincerarse y poner estos
factores en papel si es necesario para
saber cuáles de ellos están tus
posibilidades cambiar y cuáles de ellos
aceptaron
y créanme que yo en lo personal había
muchísimas cosas que no quería aceptar
pero después de darle mil vueltas en mi
cabeza de haber pensado en lo que pude
haber hecho y no hice me di cuenta que
todo lo que involucra a terceros o está
en el pasado escapa de mis manos así que
sigue colocar toda mi energía ganas y fe
en lo que sí podía cambiar y fue en ese
momento en el que comencé a ver un
cambio positivo en mi proceso de duelo
a mí me ayudaron muchísimas cosas pero
la más importante fue entender que para
superar una perdida no es sólo cuestión
de tiempo porque el tiempo no tiene la
capacidad de transformar una perdida en
algo más pero tú sí y llega un momento
en el que la vida como que te sienta y
te dice oye ya no yo sé que no te lo
esperabas y que duele pero estás
dispuesta a encontrar el para que tu
perdida
en mi caso me parece más grande fue
mejorar mi relación con mi papá vivir
más plenamente y poder hablar sin miedos
sobre la pérdida y el duelo tanto con
ustedes como con mi entorno y ojo que
este es un camino muy personal porque el
duelo es un proceso activo y no lineal
no existe una receta o ciertos pasos que
uno tenga que seguir para ya no sentir
más dolor no funciona así
simplemente aprendes a vivir con ello y
habrán días en los que te provocara
hacer absolutamente nadie quedarte en tu
cama como habrán otros en los que te
provocara salir de fiesta y divertirte
lo importante es que no te juzgues por
ello que te permita sentir hazlo te lo
mereces a mí me costó entenderlo en un
comienzo porque temía que mi papá y mi
entorno no entendieran mi forma de
llevar el duelo de mi mamá
pero lo cierto es que cada uno va
creando su propia fórmula ya sé lo que
puede con lo que tiene cada día por
ejemplo mi papá honra a la vida de mi
mamá yendo a visitar al cementerio
organizando le misas en la iglesia yo
cada vez que voy al mar veo un sunset o
me voy de viaje esa es mi manera de
conectarme con ella y no por ello quiere
decir que esté mal ni él ni yo sino que
cada uno tiene una forma de llevar la
muerte de alguien que amo y por eso es
importante que como seres humanos nos
respetemos y entendamos eso la perrilla
te brinda regalos que jamás imaginaste
pedir pero para poder recibirlos es
importante que creas de corazón que ni
la vida ni dios ni el mundo tienen algo
en contra tuyo
todos tenemos perdidas pero para poder
atravesar las es importante que cuente
su historia primero porque te das cuenta
de que no eres el único que está pasando
por ello a todos les toca el grito y
también porque es más sencillo atravesar
las cuando te apoyas en las personas que
te quieren y siguen aquí
yo en lo personal agradezco todas mis
perdidas y sé que lo que estoy diciendo
no es para todo el mundo porque sé que
varios hubieran preferido no haber
perdido a nadie ni nada para no sentir
dolor pero lo cierto es que mis pérdidas
me permitieron me permiten y me seguirán
permitiendo vivir más plenamente
agradeciendo desde lo más sencillo a lo
más complejo y entender a las personas
que están pasando por ello de una forma
que no podría hacerlo si no lo hubiera
vivido
disfruten agradezcan que hoy están aquí
y que tienen la oportunidad de hablar
con sus amigos y seres queridos sobre la
muerte hay que perderle un poquito el
miedo que sabemos que está aquí pero
desconocemos como llegó
y si algún día les toca perder a alguien
o ya lo perdieron espero de corazón que
encuentren su para qué y que puedan
recibir esos regalos que solo llegan con
el duelo gracias